just wanted to very quickly uh break in  to that ongoing transport select  committee with some breaking news  relating to the US and the FAA that's  the Federal Aviation Authority uh and  they've said that the system uh that  alerts pilots and other Personnel about  hazards and changes uh across the day uh  has been down and that has led to uh  almost all flights being grounded at  least temporarily uh data from  FlightAware uh suggesting that 400  flights or more than that were delayed  at around 5 30 a.m eastern time so  that's 10 30 a.m here and the latest  seems to suggest that um the alert  system is still not processing updates  after an outage we'll bring you more on  that but certainly some major delays at  the very least four flights due to head  to the U.S should be expected as things  stand we'll bring you more updates on  that as and when we have it but let's  see